Connor just give us a little bit of the
background to this case and why there's
been such a big political row about it
yeah huge political row huge ongoing row
here in Scotland trying to answer that
question how does the justice system
deal with prisoners who self-identify as
women and that is something that the
first Minister Nicholas sturgeon has
been taking questions on in the last few
minutes this case centers around a
double rapist who attacked two women
while they were known as Adam Graham a
number of years ago and they made their
decision to transition while awaiting
trial in that criminal case and they're
now known as Isla Bryson and they are
controversially being held in Scotland's
all-female prison Corinth and Veil and
the Sterling sure area at the Scottish
conservatives in that pretty feisty
Exchange in Edinburgh in the last few
minutes described Isla Bryson as a beast
and they said that Isla Bryson should
not be kept in that women's environment
where other women are being incarcerated
at the moment now we are told that Isla
Bryson is in segregation at this moment
in time is not within the general prison
population but that has not stopped the
questions and certainly the response
from Nicola sturgeon has been clear she
said I don't know how it's possible for
a rapist uh to be in a female prison
that was a sentiment that she agreed
with that was something that Charities
were seeing over the course of the last
few days and quite crucially Nicholas
sturgeon was clear that Isla Bryson will
not continue to be incarcerated in a
women's prison here in Scotland will not
continue to be housed at Corinth and
Vale Scotland's all female at prison
it's unclear I think at this stage
exactly where Isla Bryson will go and of
course it opens up further questions
about what happens with the rest of
Scotland's Tran population and we're
just showing you an image here of Adam
Graham who carried out these attacks
when they were known as Adam Graham
there are 15 trans people in Scotland's
prisons at this stage to put that in
context there's a wider population of
around 7 000 prisoners now the Scottish
prison service has been cleared
throughout the course of this that they
make these decisions on where each and
every prisoner should be held on a
case-by-case basis and a risk assessment
is carried out during the course of that
process now Nicholas sturgeon has said
that that risk assessment is on underway
but she was clear
the Isla Bryson's time at corintonville
is coming to an end and is coming to an
end pretty fast they are due to be
sentenced here in Scotland for those two
rapes those two sex attacks on very
vulnerable women a number of years ago
in the clay Bank area due to be
sentenced in February and the question
is whether the wider policy of the
Scottish prison service dealing with
these cases on a case-by-case basis is
open to a wider legal challenge will the
policy now change going forward for
anyone who makes the decision to
transition
from male to female or from male to
female in that situation now of course
this feeds into a wider debate a wider
discussion here in Scotland at the
moment around gender reforms of course
you will remember that there was a
pretty fiery debate just before
Christmas where Scotland decided to
change change and make it easier for
people to change their legally
recognized gender at lowering that to
the age of 16 elsewhere in the UK
someone can legally change their gender
when they are 18 there have been
widespread at criticism of that policy
from Westminster politicians the Prime
Minister they've got a secretary
attempting to block that from becoming
law here in Scotland that's a row that
is continuing to rumble on but let's now
hear from Scotland's first Minister
Nicholas sturgeon in that Exchange in
the Scottish parliament in the last few
minutes
uh firstly in general any prisoner who
poses a risk of sexual offending is
segregated from other prisoners
including during any period of risk
assessment secondly there is no
automatic right for a trans woman
convicted of a crime to serve their
sentence in a female prison even if they
have a gender recognition certificate
every case is subject to rigorous
individual risk assessment and is part
of that the safety of other prisoners is
Paramount finally in general terms and
perhaps most importantly I heard the
chief executive of root crisis Scotland
say this yesterday I don't see how it's
possible to have a rapist within a
female prison and so let me be very
clear I agree with that statement and
bearing in mind what I've just said
about the importance of individual
individualized risk assessment as a
general principle and presumption I
think that statement is great